valerian's recent massive agent changes
have completely altered how we play the
game the vct playoffs in nna are upon us
and pro teams are playing a ton of omen
still mixing in astra and viper and yes
the stim daddy himself brimstone is
finally in the competitive meta but what
does that mean for your ranked games
let me break it down for you
[Music]
okay so before we get into the video i
got to tell you
there's a bit of a cult of brimstone
here at the score esports even our
biggest valor and haters like dimitri
can't get enough of the guy so if you're
looking for some more brim daddy content
make sure you subscribe to the channel
scroll down and like the video so you
don't miss the day that i
write brimstone fan fiction or something
so as many of you already know a few
weeks ago riot games announced one of
the biggest patches in valoran's young
history which if you missed it my boy
over on cracked nile fully broke down
for you there is a lot to talk about
astra finally got nerfed the euro rework
is here and it seems as though brim and
omen might be making a return to the
meta oh and did i mention that icebox
basically got fully reworked well let's
get into the patch nets now included in
this announcement was sweeping changes
to the game's controller agents or
smokes agents they nerfed the [ __ ] out
of astro and viper while also
meaningfully buffing both brimstone and
omen they made brimstone smokes fall
much faster and added a very important
movement speed buff to his stim beacon
and with omen they made everything he
does faster the smokes travel at light
speed and his teleport is much quicker
as well and now with a full weekend of
valor champions tour challenger matches
under our belt and a couple weeks of
soul sucking rank games
i think it's safe to say that the game
is much different after this patch and
i'm talking both at the pro level and
when i'm just cueing after work with my
co-workers here at the score now before
we get into exactly how the game has
changed let's go back to before that
patch 4.04 came out astro was simply the
most broken controller and in my opinion
agent in the entire game she could stop
an entire rush from across the map and
was picked in
almost every pro match they're gonna try
and sneak their way through it on the
other side it's just so good he's
blocking him on the other side and over
again he's using these cosmic divides to
ridiculous effect sentinels can do
absolutely nothing and it's left onto
shazam although he finds two there will
be no more and i think it's fair to say
avova is the king of the cosmic divide
even if you were watching your favorite
high rank streamer you think people
would sort of mix it up in ranked but no
almost every game had an astra in it she
was just that good i mean seriously we
made a video about it literally
yesterday and let's just say
people
weren't happy about it god i hate astro
the world would be in peace if
they just removed astra from the video
game
you can just have global presence or you
can like solo hold
on imagine using four abilities all at
the same time 45 seconds wait out util
can't rush a anymore
can't do a fast mid take astral orb here
suck delayed
astra can be anywhere on the map and
stop a rush stop anything fast it's all
default bait out youtube it's not fun
for the viewer additionally with the
exception of viper on maps like icebox
and fracture
the rest of the smokes agents left a
little to be desired olmen in particular
was becoming somewhat of a meme at the
game's highest level but now
everything has changed last weekend we
saw this patch played for the first time
in pro play and while the results were
pretty staggering in all six of the
north american matches played last
weekend either brimstone or omen was
selected except was actually the only
team that didn't play either one and
what's more is that omen and brimstone
were actually the two most popular
smokers overall besting both viper and
astra so they've shut down the koal on
their side allows them to get the
paranoia off the times running out right
sentinels they've got to try and come up
with something big right now they're
trying to hold it down santa
what is that
so yeah i guess you could say that
riot's latest patch has done its job all
four of these controller agents were
selected they all had their big moments
and to be honest from a viewer's
perspective i think the diversity made
the games better v1 xander who popped
off on omen on haven and then switched
back to his bread and butter astra on
ascent spoke to a little bit of that
diversity in his post-match interview
after they took down sentinels because a
lot of the conversation coming into this
match was hey this patch kind of affects
astra negatively and you have
traditionally just been an astral player
like that has been your bread and butter
uh and in this game we were wondering
whether or not you were gonna switch
over to the omen or if you were gonna
stick to your guns in the action even
though you did play omen and haven you
did stick with the astra on ascent uh
was that more of like i don't want to
show anything off before we go into
playoffs or is this just what we should
be expecting from v1 in the future
i mean are sent us strong right now
especially with ash i think usher brings
a lot on this map and um i don't think
there was need to change it really like
we were like
really strong on this map um
but now we're like open to like playing
brim and omen on this map as well so
who knows we might switch in the future
we at the score even spoke to na's
latest golden boy trent of the guard and
he told us exactly how he thinks this
latest meta is going to break down with
astra omen and brimstone i think she'll
still be played on some maps i think
there's like two or three maps that
she's still viable on but then like the
other maps oman abram is just more
more viable i think she's viable on like
ascent
uh maybe split uh breeze i think she's
pretty so good on like for those teams
that run the breeze chamber comps
and then i think that's about it
honestly top radiant player and valence
streamer danny also shared his insight
with us about how he thinks players are
going to have to play astra specifically
going forward i don't think astra is
dead i think that the way your user has
to be different so before you can
control the entire map you can put stars
take them back and then
do all that but now you kind of have to
use it more
selfishly so
she's more of like a sentinel now where
you you have to like anchor site with
her because let's say you're trying to
help your team get map control
and you take back a star that's like 45
seconds you have to wait so to help a
team it's like more of a risk for astra
now so you can have to use your util for
yourself more
more than before and if that's not
enough evidence for you about how much
things have changed literally as i was
writing this video na's first playoff
match was going on between cloud9 and
knights and vanity instantly locked in
that omen even when the stakes were high
alright so after hearing from some of
the pro players and deep diving the last
weeks of matches i think it's pretty
clear that the game has changed quite a
bit with this patch if you're someone
who plays smokes and ranks you've
probably got some new agents to work on
that said i personally think that these
changes have actually made a pretty big
impact on how valor games in general
play out not just the agents you pick
without the full map coverage of astra's
stars the game feels a little bit more
puggy than it did before brimstone stim
beacon giving your whole team that speed
boost is allowing teams to hit sights
hard
even in ranked and that's led to a lot
more 1v1 gun fights and duels which
honestly i think is pretty dope the fact
is valerian when compared to its
counterpart counter-strike is a pretty
slow game regenerative abilities like
soba's arrow and all of this info
grabbing utility
can lead to a lot of
stalking around the map and waiting
until you find the perfect spot and then
hitting a site so now that brim daddy
himself is speeding up your whole team
so that you can hard rush into a site
and take some fights i think has made
the game a little bit more fun at least
for now i'll also note that on maps like
vine and ascent that can feel a little
suffocating for the attacker side at
times having that extra speed boost can
really help you burst out of those choke
points almost to say
i think the game has improved a lot
since the nerfs to astra and viper it's
clear to me that riot is down to take a
heavy-handed approach to balance which
is probably a good thing given that we
got more and more agents coming down the
pipeline the true test of this new meta
though will be these next two weekends
where all of na's best will be competing
for just two slots at masters i'm
personally rooting for the guard to
finish out their cinderella run i want
to see guys like trent and say a player
compete on land internationally after
all the highlights we've seen this year
what duh
i mean i don't want to why
this kid steps up in the igl to support
cryo drops down so does aaron but aaron
actually the one to fall
death does him part and now the shock
darts bcj trying to play legolas and
trent stays alive now look at the hb
it's a 1v2 and it's doable he spots out
one wallbang where is it it's a
possibility trying to learn about
trenton he finds it and now it's the one
versus one
unaware of the position of the other
last known in close to single bullet to
reveal a whole bang it is trent that's
my take but who do you have winning
those two slots from north america
let me know in the comments below
the vct playoffs in a yeah what does
this mean for your competi
which my colleague over on crack which
my boy
which my boy over o'brien
broom brimstones
brooms brimstone
brimstones brimstone
brimstone stimbee
brimstone brimstone stem beacon giving